luna the fastest easiest way to buy bitcoin
if you're just getting into crypto it's the
perfect place to start guys and welcome back to
another episode of the lehigh pen show powered
by the vc firm icon plus capital and sponsored by
block five so if you don't know block fight offer
very competitive interest rates particularly on
bitcoin and stable coins i use them i love them
so if you are interested then i'm gonna leave a
link in the description and in the comment section
i think you can get around 250 when you sign up
so pretty good so today i have um a very exciting
guest um i'm in the middle of reading his book
so it's great just to speak to him um and also
with everything that's going on in the world
right now particularly with inflation which we
found out is not transitory it's gonna be great to
speak with him so joining me today is jeff booth
entrepreneur tech leader and author of the price
of tomorrow jeff great to have you how are you
great thanks for having me leila yeah it's so good
to speak with you i think that especially during
times like this where we're seeing um astronomical
levels of inflation we were told that it was
transitory um it's clearly not quite transitory
i know you have um some really interesting um
ideas which i really want to go into and i kind
of want to start with the premise of your book
which is essentially that technology um and the
price well technology will essentially um lead to
price deflation which will then cause mass
unemployment so i'd really like to understand
exactly what you mean by this where does
technology come into play yeah so the overriding
factor in the world right now and what central
banks have been up for up against for a long time
is technology is supposed to make our lives
give us more for less which is inflationary
so that technology is productivity exponential
productivity and if you look at your phone or
or this this call we're doing if you think about
anything we do today we're used essentially
technology to do it and that technology what ends
up happening with technology is is that things
move towards the marginal cost of production
which becomes free especially with ai so if you
a really good example is 10 years ago 20 years
ago think of all the industries around camera
equipment camera sales film distribution of it
and everything else and how many photos you took
yep compared to how many photos you take today and
and the cost of it entire industries are decimated
new industries are formed and the new industries
give you way more for less we take trillions of
photos how the photos are driving part of
our culture today and it's all essentially
free the the photo the the camera on the key on
the iphone is i think it's an under five dollar
bill of materials item today and it produces 3d
and everything else so so that even that camera
10 years ago would have been 700 so so when you
think about what happens it just that that that
base layer of technology is driving everything
down in price as we're supposed to be getting more
against that and that's why i said it's been
happening for a long time now against that we
have a system that can't allow deflation so our
system that we live in is a credit-based system
and that that has to grow forever so inflationary
inflationary you have essentially you have
we believe we need two percent inflation
to survive it's just it's not true
the the system that we designed a credit-based
system that doesn't actually have hard money at
the bottom of it it's just credit requires
inflation to survive so that raises a very
interesting interesting um quandary or it's
it's it's actually the driving force of every
other thing in the world today these two things
colliding into each other one man-made system
that must that must create inflation against
technology that's trying to drive the other way
and so when you do that what ends up happening is
you concentrate wealth and power in very few hands
from then player and you're picking the
pocket of a whole bunch of other people
and they're looking out of the world and the
things that aren't being driven by technology and
there is still technology in it that let's say
housing or food hasn't transitioned as fast as
others or education education is free today people
just don't know it's free today yeah but it's um
but all of those industries that are scarce go
up in price and we and a whole bunch of people
that had their pocket picks through inflation
can't afford to live anymore and they rise up
and they vote for different leaders who carry
on the same type of tactic because the exact
entire inflationary system would
collapse without wit without manipulation
so why did why does that two percent inflation
have to have to exist why is inflation necessary
because because but what ends up happening
with an inflationary monetary policy is
and let's say the reason that exists in the
first place is because then governments can
give you more service than they can
pay for and they can hide some of that
in inflation that nobody votes for so
it can expand government's powers to
essentially pick your pockets um and and and
because we will all vote for people who will say
we would if somebody said i'm going to tell you
the truth here's what it looks like and we need
to go into a deflationary spiral and every bank
will collapse and every institution collapse
would that person get elected no and so it
so that's that's the point we all believe
that we need inflation we don't it's
it's insane to think that inflation
it's insane just to think humanity requires um
a uh a theft in their money of course to live
in a productive society it's just not true it's
categorically categorically not true what is true
is the system requires it and because because
when debt keeps on getting bigger and bigger
inflation has to go higher to pay back the debt
because you can't pay it back with taxes you
can't pay it back if you increase taxes if you
if you charge every company 100 percent taxes
next um in the us you couldn't put a dent into one
year of what is needed to run the run the budget
so access can't solve it so you have to you so you
have to resort to playing tricks and essentially
funding in a different way which is destroying
currency and hurting a whole bunch of people as
a result of that it sounds quite um inherently
um evil and like it's sort of done by design
do you think that it is done by design or do you
think it's just by accident that we ended up here
yeah i i so it would be easy to think it's
done done by design and i think there's
there's a number of books out there that uh
that that would talk about by design in the
monetary layer um well that might be true in
some senses i don't think that where we are now
is done by design i think it's more ineptitude
and and understand and and not understanding
how a system feedback loop works that that
system feedback loop making it bigger and
bigger and bigger all the time requiring
more debt all the time requiring more
um and no way out but but ask ask any policy
ask yourself if you were elected queen of the
world today how would you fix it and how would
you fix it other than an alternative system
because the system itself can't fix it because if
you if you stopped if you stopped inflating if you
allowed the free market to work people would not
want the free market to work right now because the
free market would mean every single thing would
have a cascading collapse everything every bank
would fail around the world you would have no food
on the street you're on shelves you would it would
look it would look terrible because we are so far
past the point of rescue on the existing system
so so what you could say policymakers are trying
to do and they're scared to death and rightfully
so um is there they have to what ends up happening
is when you have corruption and money you have
corruption everywhere there's a result and and
so what they'd have to do is oh look over here
and create and create more misinformation to be
able to keep printing which hurts a whole class
of people but you have to ask what would they
do what it would so so they're trapped right
unfortunately they're trapped right now and as a
result of them being trapped we are all trapped
so there's so much there to unpick so i want
to start with the idea that if we move to an
alternative system you're essentially saying
that everything would collapse banks would
collapse would be supply chain issues no food
on the streets um but i'll get into bitcoin in
a bit because i know that you every tweet you
end with bitcoin you're obviously a bitcoiner
um so how then do we how then would we even
move to a kind of world of hyper bitcoinization
if there would be this serious collapse
and i know that bitcoiners don't really
care necessarily if there's going to
be a collapse with the banks right
we're kind of almost unbanked anyway they should
care okay explain and they should care because if
you don't understand that piece you misunderstand
human nature and know what human nature would do
under those conditions yes under those conditions
um we are very susceptible to dictatorships
controlling us and doing really terrible things to
other people so every bitcoiner should care that
the existing system doesn't collapse they should
be voting for a smoothie in fact bitcoin smooth
transition and that's that smooth transition um as
mad as they are at the existing system as mad as
they are there are people in this existing
system that are that are terrible people
yeah but there's also a whole bunch of good
people in the existing system and and it's easy to
it's easy to turn against all people in an
existing system when you see the truth and
what's that existing system is most of the
what's happening in the existing system is
just momentum that has to keep on feeding
back on itself and many people have no idea
so how what would a transition look like i look
at bitcoin i look at bitcoin specifically and
that's actually why i post quite a
bit i've looked everywhere for for
understanding this problem what what possible
way what possible bridge to the other side uh
is there and i've only seen bitcoin it's the
only possible bridge i've seen i may be wrong
but but i've done investigation every uh
everywhere and i don't see another one for a
very variety of reasons but when is it what the
thing is happening today is people are looking
at bitcoin and they're looking at bitcoin
through the lens of where bitcoin is today
okay and and imagine in the u.s or canada
or any g7 nation that everything collapsed
could you use your bitcoin everywhere and and
that's the problem today you can today it's hard
yes but but what ends up happening with all
technology is people project the current
forward instead of where it's going forward so
the network on bitcoin the network effect on
layer two on bitcoin is making the roads easier
and easier to use bitcoin to be able to become a
store of value and to purchase with it and so i
i use this example i've used this example often
in 1999 when when the when the dot com market
collapsed the dot-com market collapsed and amazon
was trading at under five dollars and they
were selling books and a couple other items
what if in that time and and then
the writing was it was on the wall
that amazon was going to be this great company i
was an investor in it then i saw what it was it
was going to be this great company writing was on
the wall then they're doing the same thing today
but but what if every retail store collapsed
in 1999 and amazon wasn't selling books
you would see what what i'm talking about
the layer in the monetary layer here
right so what ends up happening is a transition
happens in the net when one system builds
and it's getting stronger and
stronger and stronger and one system
flails and gets harder and harder and harder
to be able to use and as that system starts
to flail more and more people see the new system
and they walk across the bridge to the new system
that's what bitcoin is and as more and
more people are walking across the bridge
to to build the new system both in holding bitcoin
uh yes the early people walking across the bridge
on more uh more or more of the future have more
say in the future but all people walking across
the bridge make the bridge better and better for
everyone else and it's easier and easier to use
and so all the all the investment and layer
two all the all the technology all all that
is essentially you could look at yourself myself
at this call us talking to other people who will
see this call and and say i need to get off
zero i need to understand bitcoin and and you
could see those people as becoming nodes in the
new in the new infrastructure nodes in bitcoin
which make that system stronger and stronger and
stronger over time if that happens at the right
rate then if i you if you looked at el salvador
today you could buy your groceries with bitcoin
right you can so there's places in the world that
you can start to see this transition happening
it just hasn't it just hasn't it it needs
it needs more time to move to the other side
okay so it's all about a slow transition it's
not as if tomorrow we can essentially overthrow
everything um the the existing system um
so so let me just clarify that too okay
i can't say what will happen because
when you have a system that is this
uh fragile yes anything could happen um said which
snowflake causes the avalanche we got a lot of
snow falling on the avalanche um and uh on on and
and there could be a cascading collapse any time
there could be mat and that cascading collapse
would cause massive more printing to try to stop
it but there's a lot of there's a lot of fragility
in the existing system so i'm i'm telling you what
i hope happens the healthiest way right yeah
yeah okay so that would be the healthiest way
um that slow transition infrastructure slowly
being built so people can buy their groceries
but my question really is el salvador got a lot
of hostility from the imf even the bank of england
which is laughable because of course inflation is
isn't in unprecedented levels in england yet the
bank of england are focusing on el salvador rather
than themselves and the imf the u.s so much um
hostility even christine lagarde and the president
of um the european um uh central bank she
basically said that bitcoin isn't a currency so we
can see that the establishment really don't like
bitcoin they see the power that it has so how then
is this go how is this transition really going to
take place it's as if like let's say blockbuster
versus netflix you know what if blockbuster were
powerful enough and angry enough to actually stop
the development of netflix is that possible so
so number one your question makes me laugh
because yesterday i put a tweet out that
said people in glass houses shouldn't uh made
of manipulated money shouldn't throw stones
right your glass house of the world imf lives in
and everything else throwing stones at somebody
who wants freedom and a currency that can't be
manipulated seems kind of ironic um and and so but
but more important there is every monopoly faces
the same thing um if you do the only difference
this time and is by the way it's a big difference
because we've always had a monopoly of money
that we we haven't questioned that it always will
look like that um monopolies in the economy and
and that question look at other monopolies
in an economy and what ends up happening
what ends up happening is a monopoly has its
control through scale or something else and it it
controls the access to that monopoly and and few
people are privileged the monopoly is privileged
and most people are hurt by it right any monopoly
so what protects that is those few try to
protect the walls and the end of that
monopoly what ends up happening is then
technology lowers the barrier cost the access
cost so much so and produces so much benefit
that monopoly to to change their business they
can't change the business because the access comes
from delivering value in a completely different
way your blockbuster netflix example or the
one i wrote about in the book is a good example
because the lowering of the cost of essentially
fiber and and video meant nobody had to
drive to a store to pick up a video in fact
you could in an instant technology changed the
rules and invalidated blockbuster's business and
how did it do so it opened access for a whole
bunch of people who didn't have access before
and so every technology does the same same
thing when you when you hit that point in
technology when you have kind of a 10x
value over the existing infrastructure
the existing infrastructure can't compete so and
and what ends up happening is because way more of
us way more people are hurt by the monopoly than
are helped by the monopoly all of the people that
are hurt start using the new technology or
or all the other entrepreneurs that say wow
i could never create a business over here in
this structure yeah and on this new structure
and they and they go to build their dreams hopes
empower the future on the new technology so
that actually that happens everywhere from horses
to cars to to to the printing press to to the
compute the internet every single thing looks the
same thing and a way and the monopolies that used
to stand before were built on different rules
and then technology changes the rules that's all
that's happening with uh with that's all that's
happening right now um is bitcoin specifically
lowered the barrier cost access costs everything
else from the existing system and a whole bunch
of people that are hurt by the existing system
are moving to the to the new system and that
that movement creates that bridge across to
the other side it actually makes perfect sense
that el salvador would be on bitcoin before
the us because the monopoly and and just like
it made perfect sense that no no vendor that
sold to walmart was the first seller to amazon
it was all the people who couldn't it was the
99 of products that couldn't get into walmart
went on to amazon so it's it's just what ends up
happening with any technology change yeah land of
uh the place of opportunity the blockchain right
now the land of opportunity um but you did an
interview with um andrew yang which i was actually
so happy to see um because um i want to talk about
universal basic income because he has this idea
that um with technology um developing um people
are essentially going to be put out of work and we
saw that happen um at the time of the century but
um essentially with technology speeding up right
now the whole idea that people can simply learn
to code isn't quite possible and so he believes
to sort of um i guess make that transition easier
we should have a universal basic income so i'd
love to know your thoughts on that and whether
and how you think we would transition bitcoin
aside just in general with technology moving
forward the metaverse and everything like that you
know i think i think engineers and developers are
one of the most sought after jobs right now um so
what's you know your lorry driver going to do um
when we're all sort of living in the metaverse
yeah um keep reading my book by the way
um andrew came and i don't think publicly he
can say this and everything else but he came on
almost a 180 from his belief pattern before so he
oh okay so we agreed so he we both see technology
and what it's going to do and it's going to save
time and that saving of the time comes as a result
of jobs going away like we could be we here's
the most kind of big example i could say why
don't you pay for your oxygen the air you're
breathing right now i feel like we kind of do
area breathing right now why don't you pay for it
um and and and it would be ludicrous to create an
economy where you had to pay for your the area
breathing because the hair you're breathing is
it abundant is abundant right we don't even think
like why would we do that well there are so many
places that right that that essentially technology
is going to create the same thing just like just
like so um so it's it's moving everywhere and
what it means is things should be dropping in
price as jobs come out of the market things
should be dropping in price at the same rate
the reason why basic income is is kind of used
as a fix is because you're having to you're
pushing prices up against the natural forces
and then people say i need money to live and and
it like and think about this so i create more
inflation so most prices go up and because
house prices go up and it's the only way people
can escape it's one of the only ways people can
escape that inflation blackstone starts buying
houses and then rent and then rents go up mm-hmm
and open and and people can't pay if people can't
pay their bills so so then government says wait i
need to create more inflation so i can give
them more ubi so they can pay their bills
it's insane so cause it's a cycle it's a cycle
that reinforces itself and reinforces itself and
a lot of people will vote for that cycle because
they're so hurt by the system it's like a monopoly
board going around a monopoly board somebody has
all the properties the properties they they get to
keep the properties forever there's this injection
making those properties more and more valuable and
then a whole bunch of people that are that can't
get around the monopoly board anymore and can't
end the game normally in the monopoly game would
be thrown out or the game would end right people
would break um and but they can't get around the
board so so what the people in power say instead
of give them 200 when they pass go we're going
to give them 400 and push the prices even higher
right so and then they can't get around the board
again and so that's what's so when you look at ubi
through that lens that's what it is and what it
in and andrew after that call we've had lots of
sense and everything that's cool but but he
became a bitcoin advocate after that call
because um and and but he asked me he goes how
many people understand bitcoin like you do like
the the this is the this is a transfer in systems
that that can allow humanity to flourish on the
other side and we need to get to the other side
of that that system so so i have a lots of respect
especially lots of respect for somebody who um
will will look at the facts and change their mind
um and and so uh but but but he he and he now
understands bitcoin and why it's so important
he's actually speaking in the bitcoin conference
as well oh amazing that's so good to be able to
um i guess orange pill somebody um especially a
politician um because i think i think we need more
people um on our side but in times in terms of
inflation in general i think what really concerned
me was the idea that people are um claiming that
it was it was going to be transitory um i think
um the video actually came out of the uk which
was saying um that economists didn't expect it
um which is so strange because um i don't have
a any um finance degree or anything like that
i have a journalism degree and yet i expected it
right so how do i how do i know that information
was going to come and things like
that but economists didn't so either
the economists that are um essentially in charge
because they obviously um provide financial advice
for those who make who set policy um either
they're ignorant or there's something else
going on here so how did they not know yeah so
is this so do you remember that paul krugman
uh yes that says about that about the internet the
internet it made no difference the facts machine
15 years later defending that quote i didn't know
he defended it oh i didn't know that in a big way
he defended it and he said this which is way worse
than the original quote i'm an economist i don't
make predictions on on technology so so and why
is that worse we have an economy globally that
is more and more led by technology all of it
is technology yet an economists think they're
immune from people making mistakes on technology
an economist that doesn't understand technology
it can't be a very good economist by definition
and and so and and that's the that's the thing
that's so hard in these transitions most people
most people we predict our future for our existing
path forward instead of where technology is
leading us it's very hard to understand and so
there's a whole bunch of economists that are stuck
in that same loop thinking they're playing by the
rules before and all their models are working
before as before and they simply cannot work in
the techno and where we're moving with technology
it's actually this sim is really this simple
technology moving at this rate requires a currency
that allows for deflation requirement if if
and and that requirement is almost impossible for
an existing central bank to allow right so but but
and i'm going to put a caveat on that requirement
it does it doesn't require it if you concentrate
all control in central banks and and and the
world looks like the entire world looks like china
very few people making decisions for everybody
else um but if the world looks like that it's
not a world i want my kids to grow up
in but and it and so but it but where
technology is moving how fast it's moving it
requires a currency that allows for deflation
otherwise with inflation against that
because they're opposite opposing forces
otherwise you concentrate all all wealth and
enhance ends of you it's really that simple
wow so it's the only thing that i've seen
that allow will allow that transition
okay so okay so just i'm really trying
to like understand it really it's just
the it's kind of just the push and pull and the
friction between technology which is which is
allowing for deflation in prices because of
the abundance that it's creating versus the
the essentially the monetary system that we
have which is causing inflation and then that
those two together creates this centralized power
and so so yeah exactly and and you centralize
faster and faster and faster because the because
because technology is moving one way in the uh
opposite way so so people that are thinking
you're going to have inflation forever
the minute the government stop uh printing
you're going to have a deflationary spiral
the minute and is and that's good or bad so that
would collapse the system right right right right
would it collapse into that collapse with no food
on the street and everything yes yes yes um people
us we would elect dictators to fix it for us
there would be so individual rights and freedoms
would go away a different way in if that collapse
like that without the collapse keep on printing
we elect dictators in a different way and
and so unfortunately there's only door one
keep printing um and when i say door one or door
dude or door two don't and keep printing on the
way there typically looks like revolution and war
there's high likelihood that as you keep going
even in the u.s that you have revolution um that
that trickles over and everything else as more
and more people think it's those other people
that's the problem when it's a system problem
but at a high level you have one or two doors keep
printing um all of the negative externalities from
key printing don't keep printing all the negative
externalities of that and and that's actually why
the system can't change itself it needs an escape
valve it needs this bridge to the other side
and so a lot of people that are understanding
bitcoin they're starting to walk across this
bridge and the bridge is gonna and on the other
side it's really exciting it's really exciting
for the people there's so much opportunity in the
ecosystem right now it's really exciting for the
but but this transition from one system to another
is going to be messy so both doors lead to hell
and dictatorship essentially unfortunately there
is no okay unfortunately there is no that's good
no that's a good thing wow i would say yeah it
is but it's actually also why why in bitcoin
many more people i i know i know people
do care care about this but it's so easy
to look at an unjust system and say those people
it's really all of those people and there are
people in there that know the system's unjust
and and and gain from it anyways and and and um
and will close their eyes to the gains that they
get so i understand how you could paint everybody
with a picture of a few people um and say but most
people in that system don't know what's happening
so um i have so many questions okay so how did
you i'm gonna start with this one first actually
how did you land on this realization um between
deflation and inflation um and how did you really
just realize before bitcoin that we desperately
need um an alternative system and that both doors
lead to dictatorship and health essentially um i
i've always been um this sounds arrogant no it's
fine i've always been able to see the future in
a way that other that very few my friends could
that that because because um because i know how
my own mind changes and stuff as well and i'm
not always exactly right but directionally it's
what creates it's actually why i've always been
an entrepreneur and i've created tons of value in
understanding how the technology the intersection
it's almost from asking this it's why does
the world look like this when technology could
create it to look like this and so if you just
think through that is what ends up happening is
um all of our reality from our systems we live
in and the things we use are actually ideas first
if you think about this this iphone it would
it was an idea that competed with an idea of
a blackberry that you needed keyboard and when
it first came out everybody thought it was a toy
everybody in using blackberry thought that what
a gimmick and everything yes and look at it now
but that idea was just such a radical idea and by
the way in and if you think about the evolution of
that at palm pilot which was almost the same idea
didn't hit the right step of the kind of the the
intersection of when technology changed the rules
to be able to create a better idea it was early
and and it failed yes because technology opens
up an ability to do something totally different
our minds change and we accept a new idea and
that new idea is really exciting because it
gives us so much value and so it explodes that's
what i do in business i do that everywhere in
business i've been quite successful in a whole
bunch of different companies in business boards
investments and everything else and and so from
that and and seeing all of the different things
in that i was working on and the leading edge
of what's coming in ai and 3d printing and
and and all of that i couldn't stop asking
why aren't prices going down everywhere
why prices weren't going down everywhere
like it was it was kind of a 10-year question
and i would talk about this all the time all the
time and i did not want to write a book about it
but but i'm an entrepreneur i want to i want to
when i see something that doesn't work i want i
i have to figure out to the bottom of it why not
how could it work and and so that's what led me
to to look at this and then then i realized okay
why inflation is like this why it's needed for
the existing system and but but when i looked at
the last 20 years required 185 trillion dollars of
easing to be can we work to grow the economy by
46 trillion essentially to to when i said those
angles one system is moving this way and the
other system must have the opposite effect so
you have to increase the amount of printing
to offset that over and over and over again
i could see the train wreck coming and
and in the train wreck and i realized that
my family my kids wouldn't grow up in the
same type of world that i i did and i i and
and i needed to write the book to be able to
explain that because it was driving me crazy
it was driving me crazy that you had a whole bunch
of technology entrepreneurs on one side talking
about what they were going to do and how much
money they were going to make and everything else
not being able and and and not
being able to put together the
you can't make that much money if the free market
works and the prices come down like that money is
being a derivative of of of inflation driving
driving the monopolies bigger and bigger and
bigger so google bigger so so that's why i wrote
the book i just i i eventually i got mad um i love
that good no that that's great you know i think
um we need this kind of education um i think it
upsets me that there isn't any financial literacy
in school um i have my own theories as to why that
is which a lot of people probably share um so
i you know i i love having these conversations
um you know books like yours which really just
hopefully wake people up and you know we can
try and move to a better system um so how did you
then realize that bitcoin was the answer what year
was that and um talk to me about that transition
because a lot of people obviously think it's a
scam when they first hear about it they think it's
this weird internet money that doesn't exist so um
yeah yeah tell me about your journey behind it so
i i wish i uh so i was too busy in my businesses
to be able to take this bitcoin seriously in the
beginning um and and and bunch my developers kept
coming to me and saying you got to get on this
it's really important and everything else and
i still didn't uh didn't take it seriously
um i was in bitcoin before i wrote my book
but if you'll notice on the book there's one
paragraph on bitcoin um in the book it's not a
bitcoin book it's a um and and even after i wrote
the book i was still and and am still open to any
possibility that could change this system to to
so but what i realize what i've realized and can
i'm still open if there's a but i don't see
another possibility i think to to to move to
the other side without revolution war reset to and
and if you had that you would actually build an
inflationary system on top of the reset again
just like has happened throughout history
um i don't see a another um anything that actually
competes with what bitcoin is to get to the other
other side so so that that journey to get there
and and i remember my book was written two years
ago and it's everything has played out if you
just look at that book when it was written and
you think about what's happened since it's like
it's like a road map for what's happening and what
happens next as a result of uh as a result of this
so it's it's hardened my position on on bitcoin
i think it's that important yeah i agree um
since the last two years since cover started
and all this money printing my position on bitcoin
has totally been solidified um even more so you
said that there isn't another alternative but
you are open to seeing you know if there is
one you're open to it you're open-minded which i
think is great but there are over 10 000 different
cryptocurrencies of course they aren't all the
same we've got you know let's just say a nice top
five um so what is it about bitcoin which um
really seems to be the answer compared to all
the other different um cryptocurrencies what is
it about the technology that you really admire
that's hard to do in in in a show like this and
that but i'll i'll give that a a stab the way that
the system is designed to approve for work and
decentralization um people will not make a choice
to have a deflationary currency because there's
too much wealth and power to be able to design
as a different system so us we won't make
that choice and that's why the the the the
the decentralization essentially
that's driven into the
into the protocol the security proof of work
that that that security is a feature that
proof of work is a feature of the system
the energy use and require it for bitcoin
is the thing that keeps it decentralized
and it's a feature of the system that that
stops humanity from actually changing the
rules so that's that's a big big part of it
now but let's just say okay bitcoin versus
ethereum so bitcoin tries to win store value
this innovation and everything else and and and
it does so and it does so over time and remember
if if bitcoin came out today and everybody knew
what it was today and it was in its infancy
it would have been shot down today today like so
if it so if it came out and it was a small market
cap and everything else and it had this dream of
being able to do this regulators would shut it
down because now they know what it means right
think about what's happening with the imf when
you think about what happens with china when you
think about people are trying to shut it down and
they can't shut it down it's impossible um but but
in year two they might have been able to bitcoin
so you had this this evolution and this this
system that got hardened and hardened and hardened
before people woke up to realize that it's a
redistribution of power away from central power
to human humanity and and and so and and so now
it it's it's far enough along that that its heart
is very very difficult to stop so now enter other
alt coins and because bitcoin was going after that
it let's the use ethereum as example wow this is
a really interesting blockchain can do this and
everything else how do we make money but that
looks more like a company making making money
and we're gonna and so so a small group of people
do a pre-sale a pre-mine and say a world computer
and it's gonna be blockchain for everything
else i actually do understand why
ethereum would have a network effect
today um doing nfts and everything else
but the design of the system in fees makes it less
secure and you have to central and you have to
have to centralize and you keep changing
the design of the system yeah and you have
to keep and and and it's not just it is you keep
changing it by the people who control the system
and so and and then altcoins underneath that as
fees go up on ethereum it opens up attacks from
below on oh i can do the same thing for less
cost and you have tons of different alt coins
so i'm not necessarily against people making their
own choice on their free market investment they
can make advice and everything else the i just
categorically i don't believe they have any value
in the long term i think what ends up happening
is the design of bitcoin kind of on layer one
what ends up happening on
layer two and layer three
why do you need those other coins i think
everything starts to aggregate to the winner
because um because all of those all of those
use cases can be designed on something that's
way more efficient and reinforces the primary one
so so so it's not um i just think yeah i wouldn't
again i'm an investor in technology lots of
technology companies and i i i tend to think
what would i what do i believe and what would
i put my money in and and and set it and forget
it um i wouldn't do that on a whole bunch of
altcoins um in in bitcoin i can easily do that
i love that um i love hearing those kind of um
arguments but in terms of just the other side um
of um what we were talking about going through
those doors and reaching the other side with a
better system um how do you then see it played out
so do you do you actually see a world where things
are denominated um in satoshi's um so how yeah
tell me how you see it and also do you think that
would see only certain states certain countries
adopting this new technology or is that just part
of the transition how does the future look is part
of the transition and so so so what gives the us
dollar um strength is besides kind of using oil
and energy through a war machine to be able to
price and oil in u.s dollars what what gives the
u.s dollar strength around the world is a network
effect that it's used everywhere it's a common
currency everywhere as that happens with bitcoin
as more and more countries users and everything
else start to do it and layer two with lightning
or liquid and start to start to use that this
more and more people that's what i meant about the
network effect more and more people the on-ramps
the technology the different things the use cases
it's way easier to use bitcoin and be secure
in bitcoin today than it was five years ago
the on-ramps are way easier it's simple and the ux
and the design and there's and so the innovation
coming into this ecosystem is bringing more and
more people in that if i want to hire an engineer
in um in india um without going through government
without going through a bank by the way i i i it
took three weeks one time to get a six-figure wire
transfer about two months ago to india through
it's just a nightmare through the existing system
and all paperwork and everything else i don't need
to do that anymore i can i can hire anybody
anywhere and i can start trading with those
those those those people through a different
through an altered network um that network
is in its infancy but it's growing leaps
and bounds and more and more people are
moving onto that network which opens up more
and more so that's the transition that we're
talking about and states can't stop it
because because because people everywhere
where a state has tried to stop bitcoin it's
accelerated why yes because because because
they're essentially screaming at you with a
megaphone that says here's why you need it
yeah i think it's so interesting
and we saw that happen with china
saw that happen in nigeria all it does is
either further decentralize the network or it
forces people to end up trading um peer-to-peer
which was the initial goal in the first place
um so yeah it's really interesting i want to
just move on slightly so i know we're obviously
short for time at this point but i'd love to talk
about entrepreneurship because obviously you've
had um tremendous success um especially with build
direct so i kind of want to understand um firstly
do you think that anybody can be an entrepreneur i
think anybody can i just don't think people are uh
geared uh towards it and i think and and
why is they perceive risk differently
so so they don't perceive risk of his status quo
they think status quo is safety and they perceive
so a lot of people would look at
entrepreneurs as these enormous risk takers
i categorically just disagree we're because here's
the way i look at an entrepreneur at being one
i'm in i i'm i'm actually i'm risk adverse
i just i see the risk in the existing system
and i don't want a job in the existing system
where i have no control over my destiny and even
if i go in over here and and and under so that's
actually why i would chase down to the sand will
this work or not what will it take and because
it's a bet on yourself it's bet on your team
it's a bet on what you have to do to change to
create the opportunity and so even if you fail
you come out of that learning with so much
learning that the next time it's easier
and so um so i i think great entrepreneurs
aren't risk takers they're asymmetric debt takers
that's such a good point um because i remember
years ago um i was living in a country um and i
loved my job and i was so happy that the job
brought me to that country but the company
was failing and so i had to leave the country
and i was so upset because now i didn't have
control over where i lived and it was from that
moment that i said to myself i can't ever rely
on an exterior party to basically determine how
my life is going to look so at that point i was
like no i've got to make my own money um i can't
do that so i yeah so i could totally get that so
a lot of people watching um are trying to build in
this industry in the crypto space so what advice i
know it's really cringy but it has it is actually
very helpful what advice would you give somebody
who is looking to start building um especially in
the world that we're living in right now um a lot
of people do feel that opportunity opportunities
are being taken away um just given travel
restrictions and inflation and things like that
so what kind of words of wisdom would you give
someone looking to build right now there's so much
i wish i was younger because there's something
right there literally is um because as any time
there's chaos in the world um there's system
transitions entrepreneurs um are required to be
able to move that forward hopes dreams everything
else and on their hopes and dreams do we ride
as a civilization that's what ends up happening
and and so so when you look at system problems and
those system problems create a whole bunch of pain
for other people understanding how you can fix
that pain is what an entrepreneur does and when
you when you do that in a way that delivers tons
of value the business is bound to be successful
now doing that figuring that out is which market
how does it how do i do this how do i focus
but i'll give you an example of what's happening
today to so then existing industry and you could
use twitter's new ceo you could you could use
google you could use facebook you could use
our communication channels are
getting more and more controlled
and they're getting more and more control and what
ends up happening to build these monopolies what
ends up happening is you you have to attract
people who will deliver let's use youtube as
an example people who deliver different content
to your system which attracts users and so people
think it's attracting users that's the trick
it's not it's a tracking contract providers
and then as more and more content providers
come in and they're and if you think about
how many hours of youtube are uploaded a day and
most of that is not seen what ends up happening
is there's so much competition to try to be that
found and more users are attracted to the platform
mm-hmm those platforms are monetized today are
youtube gets all the money through advertising and
these people are essentially selling their souls
through advertising and they get one percent two
percent half a percent of the advertising break
to be able to to to meet a buyer on layer two
on lightning and what's happening on on lightning
that whole thing will be reinvented and it will be
reinvented everywhere lots of other opportunities
but that whole industry would be reinvented in in
that if content is the value and most of the
content producers are getting very very little
value then there's an opportunity on a system
that lowers the barrier cost because because
because google system requires that barrier
cost because it was built on a different model
on lightning it lowers the barrier costs and
there's somebody that could come out and say
listen i need three percent to run the business or
five percent business to run the business but 95
of the value is yours where do you
think the content producers would go
lightning and as you did that what do you think
if the content producers are all going there
where do you think the people would go and and
and and that's and and so you're able to recreate
a whole bunch of value by giving more people
value the change to change change business that's
just one example but that example would be in a
whole bunch of different places on the new rails
uh commerce that are coming so it's true when
people say bitcoin fixes this um you know we could
start actually seeing those kind of decentralized
systems on the bitcoin network um you know youtube
alternatives and stuff like that yeah that's what
i expect to happen yeah that'll take a bunch of
time but once that network effect starts to to
to spin it'll spin faster and faster and faster
amazing so what are you working on right now
is there another book in the works i know you
said you didn't really want to write one and of
course right now i doubt it i'll probably put
up free content rather than the uh yeah and
i do a bunch of these podcasts to be able to
get out i'll never say never because maybe i'll
get mad again on something else but um but the um
this is moving i think it's inevitable
and and people like you a whole bunch of
influencers in in this community i would
rather just take the message forward um
and and and and build it i can
just slide off in the background
well i really appreciate you coming on jeff
it's been so interesting i'm really excited
to continue reading your book where can people
um follow you and find your book probably just
best on on twitter uh at jeff booth the book's
called uh the price of tomorrow why deflation
is key to an abundant future and amazon's
probably best spot for that jeff i want to
thank you so much it's been such a pleasure and i
want to thank everyone for tuning in thanks a lot
all right we'll speak soon and guys don't forget
to tune in next week for another brilliant guess